Michelle is in New Orleans I'm Michelle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I have recently gotten
engaged and congratulations thank you I
found out that my fiancee is about two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
debt he makes about $90,000 a year but
forty seven thousand dollars of that
goes to his ex-wife for child support
and maintenance I've never been in debt
and I honestly don't know how where we
would even start to get out of this debt
mm-hmm what do you make of it I make
about twenty six thousand dollars a year
and I work in the big economy and how
how old are you guys I'm 36 and he's 38
what is his bet from it's basically from
the divorce he owes about $70,000 to his
ex-wife $45,000 on a vehicle that he
turned in for a voluntary repossession
$30,000 to her lawyer and his lawyer and
about $75,000 in credit card debt he got
his butt whipped yes he did his lawyer
was awful yes he ends up paying
everything yes he absolutely ended up
paying everything whenever the divorce
went through he was making about 125
thousand dollars a year and why does he
know like that now we went through the
flood and 2016 and we he lost his job I
lost my job and so he's gotten back he
works in the plant he's gotten back to
working but he had to go with a
different company and they offered him
five dollars less an hour why the other
company never reopened right what is he
good he works he's a heat reader and the
plant
here in Louisiana okay don't work in the
other part of the story I want to get
straight in my head it sounded like you
didn't know how much debt he had until
after you were engaged yes why I I was
not aware I was not very smart and I
didn't ask him about his debt I've never
had debt it didn't cross my mind well I
should have crossed his yeah that you
should have had this information prior
to making a commitment to marriage yes
that's kind of a problem like he was
hiding it okay that bothers me more than
the debt right this moment and so what's
his attitude about the debt he really
hasn't been paying anything towards it
and I just don't want to start a
marriage now that I know about the debt
I can accept that
I just before we actually set a date to
get married I want to know that we are
on a plan to get this paid off there you
go and that he believes in that plan and
is committed fully to that plan yeah if
he if he is for whatever reason has
given up hope and it feels like he's
stuck he's just gonna stay there or he
just doesn't care or whatever about the
debt if for whatever reason he's just
gonna wallow in this that's a
deal-breaker okay it's not the debt I
wouldn't tell you to not marry him over
the debt but I would tell you to not
marry him over lying about it or not
marry him over the fact that he wants to
just stay in it because you're not gonna
be you know it's a long life full of
Hell for you okay if you you know think
about it 10 years 15 years from now
you're still wallowing in this stuff
you're not gonna be okay with that no
that's what I absolutely don't want to
do yeah and so it's not you know and if
he's not gonna be all-in like we live on
nothing and you know he probably just go
back to court and adjust some stuff and
I don't think he owes $45,000 on the
repo I think that's what he owed on the
car at the
they repoed it Falkon he owed when they
recode seventy thousand yes what was he
driving a suburban which i think is
absolutely outrageous yeah and he rolled
some negative equity into that to get to
there okay and so that the forty five
thousand is the difference okay they'll
settle that for pennies on the dollar
you probably settle that for ten grand
but the rest of stuff I don't know I
mean the ex-wife thing I don't know what
you're going to do with that
how in the world ends up owing her and
these two attorneys while you may be
able to settle those with lump sums I
mean you might walk up to her and say
here's a check for thirty if you'll go
away and she might take it you know but
you'd have to have the thirty thousand
dollars is what I'm talking about here
not thirty dollars and so you know
you're going to put some money together
here and that means both of you are
going to get your incomes up and you
both have to have I desire to get out of
money or to get out of debt and to make
more money to do that you have to both
have this thing and it's still going to
take you a few years I mean if you guys
just go bananas it's going to take you a
few years so that's what you're facing
and but the thing is folks here those of
you dating out there it is not a
deal-breaker as far as I'm concerned it
can be for you you can decide what you
want to do it's your life but I don't
tell people to not get married over that
I do tell them to not get married over
the decision to stay in that when you
don't want to stay in that because
that's gonna be when you can't be an
agreement on money before you get
married when money is the number one
cause of divorce we can highly predict
that your marriage is not going to last
it's it's if okay if the number one
cause the divorce you don't agree on
guess what you're gonna get divorced I
mean that it's a fairly simple equation
here and so you have to be in agreement
so I don't the 250 doesn't scare me it
scares me but it doesn't terrify me to
say this guy's not a keeper I don't know
if he's a keeper or not
I can't tell he sure has a bad taste in
lawyers and
that because he got his butt whipped but
anyway man he ends up paying her lawyer
his lawyer was her 70 grand and half of
his income not a four that's half good
gosh so Wow
yeah somebody so anyway yeah the this
was not an equitable outcome I have no
idea what situation was but wow what a
mess
anyway so all of that's behind us now
the question is are we committed to
cleaning it up if we are then ready to
go
game on that's fine thanks for the call